it took him out of the game completely
he had the turnovers in the second half
as zion just
pulls his way through her sean holmes
wow
the pelvis having a look how he doesn't
use his off arm but he just gets rashaan
holmes off with his upper body
it goes down goes down a little bit a
little
he is a long guard 6'5 and a good
wingspan
and a good move it'll be zion on the
hammer
metoo doesn't know it hit him there
our energy power play early very early
you want to see a dead body
bang that is like to be in this place
that is
so incredibly quick though the fake
right and then the drive back left
wow
i wish we were courtside that's in hayes
and he goes away from the pick
this is the pass and
you talked about kyrie lewis earlier he
may not be shooting the ball well
he may he may be struggling 1-6 from the
field but he is making
excellent decisions with this basketball
i like the way he's getting into the
teeth of the defense
and then making the decisions you're
talking about that's a good time
cut that's knowing your personnel
knowing zion's not going to stay out
there and spot up for three
knowing that he's going to come to you
that's good that's a good
strong finish by zion at the rim as well